eu education ministers will look at ways
to ensure that today's young people are
equipped with the necessary skills to
succeed in an increasingly digital
environment they will also review the
achievements of european cooperation in
the fields of education and training and
assess whether there is room to improve
this cooperation in the future
following up on the informal meeting of
eu education ministers in march in paris
the council will also stress the
importance of promoting citizenship and
the common values of freedom tolerance
and non-discrimination through education
aware that youth unemployment rates
remain high and so does the risk of
social exclusion the council will also
consider how to reinforce youth work and
how to better address the socio-economic
challenges facing young people
the council will also discuss the future
european audiovisual policy the
convergence of online and traditional
media is becoming a reality for more and
more european citizens it opens up new
opportunities for industry and consumers
but it also brings new challenges for
policy makers and regulators including
how to ensure the quality and the
cultural diversity of the digital offer
as concerns cultural heritage issues
ministers will also be briefed about the
extent of the destruction of cultural
sites perpetrated by isis daesh in iraq
and syria finally eu ministers will seek
to maximize the role of grassroots sport
in the life of citizens especially young
people to enhance their participation in
society and their employability